on va parler d'un autre sujet qui cesse
de faire parler depuis ce weekend c'est
la mort de Thomas un jeune de 16 ans qui
a été tué au couteau lors d'une fête
dans un village de la drrome Géral
haranin s'estexprimé aujourd'hui il a
annoncé que SEP interpellations ont eu
lieu aux alentours de Toulouse euh
justement ils ont fui à
toulouseou est-ce qu'ils voulit pas
partir en Espagne c'est ce que je
pensais ou voilà c'est ça c'est ça ah
ouais c'est ce que c'est ce que je me
suis dit tout de suite ouis ils ont ils
voulent à mon avis passer la frontière
et partir en Espagne et aujourd'hui ils
ont interpellé les 7p jeunes
dont Gilles celui qui serait l'auteur
présumé
de l'auteur présumé a été arrêté après
une une course poursuite autour d'un
restaurant donc en fait effectivement
d'après les premières infos il voulait
partir en Espagne ils font l'erreur mais
bénéfique pour l'arrestation ils font
l'erreur de louer des chambres d'hôtel
et comme il y avait eu des vidéos et des
images diffusées sur les réseau ils ont
été repérés par les gendarmes donc les
gendarmes les ont suivi les ont vu le
gignn local gig national armé parce
qu'il pensait que ces gens étaient
dangereux arrivent et donc réussi à les
interpeller alors euh aujourd'hui euh
l'interpellation donc vous nous AZ dit
vous avz passé oui c'est ça très musclé
très musclé parce que ils voulaient fuir
ils ont essayé de fuir de partir et les
policiers les ont suivi voilà donc là
ils ont plusieurs personnes
effectivement ils pensent avoir l'auteur
des coups et on va dire que les forces
de l'ordre ont été très efficaces dans
cette affaire vous êtes d'accord he
parce queoua
justement on attend la justice et il y a
éc Dupont Moretti qui a poussé un coup
de gueule contre mais pas contre tout ce
qui se passe il a poussé un coup de
gueule contre la récupération politique
du RN bah oui il il a poussé un coup de
gueule contre ça donc c'est ça le danger
si ça vous convient non al mais regardez
n vous savez on est à côté de la plaque
regardez la vie enlevée de ce gosse de
16 ans méritait à l'évidence un moment
de silence et de recueillement il a
immédiatement été substitué par un
moment de polémique il n'y a pas de
hasard il n'y a que des rendez-vous les
rendez-vous du malheur que vous honoré
qu'il s'agisse de la petite Lola qu'il
s'agisse du petit Clément les auteurs de
ces faits seront jugé par une cour
d'assise composé d'un jury populaire
comme le sont tous les crimes de
sang non mais n'applaudissez pas plat
applaudir non plus excusez-moi
franchement excuse-moi hommesqu un DESC
arrê c'est un descend excusez-moi il y a
a un petit il y a un jeune qui a pris un
coup de couteau il y a mourade qui s'est
fait truc et lui il vient nous parler du
RN arrêtez arrêtez alors que la justice
est dans un état lamentable arrêtez for
de dire tout le temps ça et dans dans un
dénis absolu en fait on règle pas les
problèm Thomas c'est que l'extrême
droite et
mour nous on n pas le droit de dire que
c'est dramatique dans les deux cas en
faème politique c'est un problème de
justice moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
j'aurais préféré que le ministre de la
Justice et le garde des sauts disent
voilà on va je peut vous dire qu'il va
avoir des peines exemplaires et que qui
parle de l'affaire Mourad qui disent bah
Mourad le gars qui est dehors là
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est inadmissible
le gars qui insulté Moad de bouou
insultes racistes et qui disent bah oui
et aujourd'hui les jeunes là les se
jeunes qui ont qui ont poinardé un petit
un petit de 16 ans qui avait rien à voir
là-dedans le pauvre qui joue au rugby
qui était tranquille qui faisait sa vie
tranquille eux je vais les et je vais
voilà dans ses termes à lui il aurait
dit je vais les attraper je peux vous
dire qu'ils vont manger
SV juste dire ça juste dire ça venir
venir parler et et faire 3 minutes sur
le RN excusez-moi les Français ils en
ont rien à [__] les Français ce qu'ils
veulent c'est des peines exemplaires ils
en ont Mar des gens comme vous même
Valérie je t'aime beaucoup gens comme
vous qui disent oui non non excusez-moi
làc on s'en fout la récup
minist le ministre de la Justice on lui
demand pas de faire de On Demand demand
des sanctions exempla ministre de la
Justice donc moi j'aimerais bien
l'entendre sur un certain nombre de
jugement pardon mais quand même le
ministre parle pas comme un homme d'État
il parle pas comme un homme qui
l'assemblée qui s'adresse au français il
parle pas comme un ministre de la
justice il parle comme un
avocatoc nous raconte des faits les Gard
des saau machin jur populaire on s'en
fout nous on veut que tu prennes tes
coron et que tu dises voilà je vais
m'occuper de cette situation en France
où maintenant tu peux mourir d'un coup
de couteau et te retrouver chez toi le
soir moi j'aurais j'aurais aimé qu'il
dise un mot sur mourade je suis désolé
voilà au lieu de parler du
R je peux vous dire ça aurait été
beaucoup plus efficace de dire voilà moi
je vais vous dire aujourd'hui pour moi
je suis le garde des sauts il y a une
décision de justice qui est inadmissible
ce
garçon exactement c'est comme sur LoL
comme sur Lola parce que vous le savez
lui et moi on est pas on n pas potte
hein depuis l'affaire Lola il parle de
moi dans toutes les émissions voilà je
vais vous dire donc il faut quoi comme
preuve encore il faut quoi comme Pr on
en est où on en est où de faire on en
est où ça avance très doucement il m'a
il a parlé de moi pendant des semaines
et des semaines dans toutes les
émissions en disant c'est inadmissible
ce qu'a dit cil Hanouna sur l'affire
Lola la différence entre Éric Dupont
moréti et moi c'est que moi je parle
avec mon cœur Éric Dupont Moretti parle
avec son portefeuille politique mais c
en plus ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'il
est ministre de la Justice on s'attend à
ce que il défende les juges qu'il
défendent la magistrature qu'il nous
explique comment ça fonctionne là on
l'attend là-dessus on l'attend pas sur
une attaque politique on a l'impression
que dès qu'ils ont un f tu sais je
dire ils onvie de taper un
coup me entre je dis pas ça parce que je
voilà je dis j'aime bien je trouve qu'il
en tout cas il est sur tous les front il
est sur tous les fronts il y a eu Mourad
il a dit c'est inadmiss il y a
eum du PTI ça fait des semaines et des
semaines qu'on le voit pas il s'exprimé
sur rien ex par contre on a pas beaucoup
parler d'ailleurs on va parler ici les
gars parce que je pense que demain il
faut quand même qu'on fasse un point
quand même sur é D qui été donc on
attend le jugement attend de jugement 2
on parlera Gérard Darmanin ex-moi il y a
un mec qui bosse Géral Darmanin il y a
un mec qui fait des coups d'class DUP
morti et son truc à chaque fois c'est de
parler du RN les mecs on n pas là il y a
pas d'élections là qui vont arriver là
bientôt là c'est
insupportablearrte pas de
lesentendre exactement alors que les
gens se posent énormément de questions
sur ce qui s'est passé dans ce village
de la Drome on tout le monde a envie
d'avoir informations des enquêteurs
puisqueapparemment effectivement ça va
très très vite et que des ministres de
la Justice puissent s'exprimer sur
quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'enquête je trouve ça très très alors
il y a des gens qui vous disent oui il a
pas le droit de s'exprimer parce que
l'enquête est en cours et C on s'en fout
c'est le Ministre de la
justiceê
humê il peut faire humain et rassurer
les Français et dire je vais m'occuper
de votre sécurité parce que les Français
c'est la sécurité ils ont pourme lui qui
parlé d'un sentiment
d'insécurité
derrière de rien ça fait pas son travail
et que on va prendre des risques pour
rien combien de fois j'ai vu des gars
qui m'ont dit c qu'est-ce que je vais
aller prendre un risque pour prendre un
coup de couteau une pierre dans la tête
un truc un ti de mortier pour faire quoi
pour que les mecsessortent de jours
après qu'est-ce que je je
m estent on est souvent jeis donner ex
parce que bon j'ai vécu les émeutes
pendant une semaine et j'étais sur
plusieurs plateaux et j'étais souvent
pris à parti par la LFI on l' vu aussi
euh même si on en a parlé dans le cadre
de l'affaire Naël où on entend certains
députés de la LFI qui tiennent des
propos et qui attise cette haine qui
attise vraiment la haine contre la
police et je suis désolé de le dires ils
ont une responsabilité oui et en fait
qui victimise moi mes parents en tout
cas parce que bon comme vous l'AZ
constaté je suis pas je suis originaire
même si je suis français je suis
d'originaire originaire d'origine
maghrébine pardon et êtes à 19 marococ
mais à 19h j'étais chez moi et j'ai vécu
dans des quartiers et je sais que tous
les parents ne peuvent pas faire ça mais
aujourd'hui à l'époque pour nous les
députés les élus étaient des exemples et
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est encore
des exemples mais il y en a qui tiennent
des
propos c'est comme là sur sur je le dis
aussi sur sur les cités sur les
quartiers est-ce qu'on a entendu un acte
pour l'instant est-ce qu'on a entendu
des des drames dans les dans les dans
les quartiers pour l'instant tout se
passe bien et moi j'ai tous mes potes
qui me disent nous FuG Reb tout et ben
ça se passe très bien ça se passe au
contraire nous on veut on est et
aujourd'hui je dis je le dis la LFI met
énormément d'huile sur le feu je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi et attise
une haine envers votre corporation qui
est inadmissible et je peux vous dire
quand vous entendez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en meeting et que le lendemain vous vous
faites arrêter par un policier je peux
vous dire un gars de un gars qui a
écouté Jean-Luc Mélenchon 2 he il a
qu'une envie c'est de vous insulter donc
forcément ça va mal se passer et je vous
le dis donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est ça et aujourd'hui je le redis Éric
Dupont Moretti garde des sauts je suis
désolé dans un moment pareil on on on
parle pas de politique on essaie
vraiment déjà de rendre hommage aux
victimes de rendre hommage aux familles
et de dire voilà et de dire aux familles
et de dire aux victimes voilà
aujourd'hui on va faire le maximum pour
qu'il y ait des peines exemplaires pour
ce qui se passe ce qui est fou c'est
qu'on a l'impression que G est ministre
de l'Intérieur et ministre de la justice
c'est ça le truc c'est que Girin qui
prend la parole pour dire il va y avoir
des peines exemplaires voilà et derrière
bah derrière derrière ça suit pas g
qu'est-ce que tu en pens je suis assez
d'accord avec vous sur le rôle
complètement presque inexistant
contreproductif de Monsieur Dupont
Moretti pour moi il a jamais endossé les
habits je vais vous le dire de de garde
vaau il a pas pris la hauteur et il est
resté effectivement comme disait r mon
avocat comme il est mal àaise du coup
euh il a il est il est pas dans son rôle
il est pas dans son rôle moi je pense je
pense que au moment de son procès il
aurait fallu dire voilà on va changer et
on verra plus tard je pense que là en
plus il est à contrepied total donc il
est pour moi inopérant vous avez raison
et du coup le ministre de l'Intérieur
double son poste il le fait avec
efficacité mais d'abord il est ministre
de l'Intérieur nous même symboliquement
un ministre de la Justice mis en examen
même s'il évidemment pris c'est quand
même très compliqué c'est un signal qui
est compliqué est inoc très compliqué
après on va voir ce qui va se passer
mais là forcément ça
va ça va être très compliqué derrière
euh la mer juste CIR un mot sur que dans
Paris Match oui justement la mère de
Thomas donné une interview exclusive
après avoir vu la dépouille de son fils
elle dit que c'est de la folie furieuse
rendez compte cette maman elle voit son
fils partir à une fête elle revient pas
cet été on l'avait autorisé à aller à
quelques balles de village et pour celui
de crpol il avait hâte raconre sa mère
c'est juste à côté de chez nous et sur
les 300 ou 400 participants il devait
connaître 80 % des jeunes il est allé
avec son frère de 23 ans tous les
copains de Thomas devaient dormir à la
maison ça n'est jamais arrivé h nous
étions partis en weekend à 200 km de là
et son frère nous a appelé il disait
qu'il n'avait pas réussi à sauver son
frère on est rentré immédiatement on a
pu parler au SAMU qui a tenté de le
sauver ils nous ont dit qu'il ne parlait
déjà plus
elle dit ensuite avec émotion que c'est
un meurtre et et qu'elle espère que les
gendarmes vont rapidement mettre la
mains sur les agresseurs ça je pense que
son souhait va êté puce que ça y est je
pense qu'on a les les auteurs des fait
auteurs présumés des faits elle dit qui
vient à une soirée avec des couteaux il
voulait en découdre j'espère que les
gendarmes vont rapidement trouvver qui a
fait ça ça ne nous le ramènera pas mais
au moins ça les empêchera de faire
d'autres meurtres oui c'est un meurtre
qu'ils ont
fait
surtout Isabelle à qui on pense très
très fort ce soir et toute la famille de
de Thomas son son frère aussi rendez
compte son grand frère on décte son
grand frère dans l'état dans lequel il
est où il dit j'ai pas pu sauver mon
petit frère en plus il en avait la la
responsable abilité euh et c'est vrai
que si ça merre je je pense qu'on va on
va on a retrouvé les les auteurs
présumés de de de de ce ce drame mais
surtout c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
justice exemplaire c'est ça parce que si
c'est pour avoir encore euh des jeunes
qui vont sortir parce que sur les SEP h
déjà il y en a qu'un qui va être
certainement pourui pour homicide
volontaire ou peut-être enfin présumer
donc ça veut dire les si autres on verra
ce qui va se
[Musique]
passer truc qu'il y a aujourd'hui ce qui
est fou c'est que c'est comme on voit
dans
l'affaireour si mour éta mort ser en
prison aujourd'hui l'auteur des faits ça
s passé à ça et en fait c'est pas la vie
de Moad qui l'a sauvé c'est sa vie le
présumé l'auteur présumé donc c'est ça
qui est fou c'est que
aujourd'hui je suis désolé mais
tentative d'homicide ou homicide il faut
que la peine soit vraiment c'est c'est
pour moi c'est c'est c'est c'est voilà
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est un c'est
c'est pratiquement la même chose c'est
quoi c'est juste c'est en fait si on est
mal àroit on va pas Plon c'est quand
même on est récompensé parce qu'on est
maladroite et je vous dire sur ces deux
affaires qui sont complètement
différentes ça montre bien ça montre
quelque chose de d'incroyable vous
l'avez vu he hier tout le monde disait
ou avant-hier c'est inadmissible vous
avez vu des jeunes des quartiers qui ont
été poignardé un jeune homme de 16 ans
aujourd'hui AC laaffire mourada vous
avez vu hein aujourd'hui la fille vous
avez vu avez vu ça c'est un gars de
l'extrême droite qui a dû poignarder
enfin qui qui a tailladé
un un jeune jardinier mourade et c'est
vrai que là-dessus je suis d'accord avec
dupti sur ce petit point c'est que les
récupération Politi on a rien à [__]
je vous dis ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y
en a un qui a la gorge tranchée et il a
une mère Isabelle qui a perdu son fils
de 16 ans mais la récupération elle est
elle est ENF elle est tellement profond
c'est dire que la LFI ne tweete pas sur
crpol et l'extrême droite ne tweete pas
sur rendezte la
FOL la folie oui mais er
d avait d'autres priorités excuse-mo
pr pr libtion son enemi c'est le r parce
que il s'est dit tiens ça fait bien même
la presse libération sur 30 pages ne
parle pas du drame de crepol c'està-dire
que idéologiquement aujourd'hui la
presse généraliste elle prend son camp
c'està dire qu'on est ou d'un côté ou de
l'autre ben non désolé nous on est des
deux moi je voudrais être des deux côtés
en fait autant mourade que Thomas voilà
moi je c'est ça on est autant mourade
que Thomas je suis désoléè je pense que
est autant mour que Thomas regardez le
sondage voilà 82 % bon à mon avis je
vous ais quand même un petit peu inf
mais bon merci quand même hein mais bon
non je pense que vous avez votre propre
avis mais c'est 82 % des gens sont assez
d'accord avec moi sur les propos de
Erric duponoriti je vais qu'on voit
quelque chose ce matin parce que il y a
eu un sujet sur le le drame survenu à
crpol et il y a un géralde brillant qui
n'a rien à voir avec Danis un ancien
commissaire divisionnaire a traité de
raciste Jean-Marc Morandini pendant
l'émission je crois que c'est quelqu'un
qui sa quoi ça un communiste par
communiste
VI vous
alleou raciste comme
d'habite qui par de R qui a parlé de R
qui a parlé de r attendez stop stop
c'est très grave ce que vous dites qui a
parlé de race mais vous êtes racésol
vous êtes racistedon vous êtes
raciste alors donnez-moi
exempleendeznezo exemple exemple je
trouve raciste constamment
exemplestamment donnez-moi un exemple
mais c'est votre car carère donnez-moi
pardon vous me fatiguez vous me fatiguez
parz monsieur partez attendez attendez
attendez partez si je vous fatigue je
n'accepterais pas que vous me tratiez de
racist sur ce plateau c'est de la
diffamation alors euh c'est devenu le
nouveau truc he des gars quand ils
savent plus quoi dire ils disent qu'on
est raciste c'eston avait on a eu le
problème avec Louis Boyard ici le génie
des temps modernes qui était làin sur ce
plateau voilà hein qui qui avait sorti
aussi le même argument quand ils ont
plus rien à dire ils disent que voilà
qui disent que est est raciste il était
cornérisé parce que Jean-Marc mandini
essayit de lu de lui faire dire pour
quelle raison il ne voulait pas il va
pas employer un autre mot que le mot r
une r effectivement c'est de bandes qui
s'affrontent là
l'urence la FP parle de trouble fait
pour les jeunes qui sont ont tué qumeel
ou
voil
trouble fait c'est
scandaleux quoi oui non rien rien là je
ne défends pas mais pr amis non non non
non non c'est pas mes amis mais encore
une fois je les défends pas raciste
comme ça c'est parfaitement diffamatoire
donc ça s'attaque en justice voilà il
peut attaquer
làdessus totalement incapable de
formuler quelque chose d'avoir un
raisonnement il dit non mais je vous
trouve raciste c'est génial on peut on
peut aujourd'hui sur un plateau de
télévision on peut traiter quelqu'un et
puis bah il y a aucun raisonn il y a
aucun aucun aucun argumentaire qui va
avec mais c'est juste des mots à
l'emportepièce comme ça merci merci
d'avo so sor du plateau on pense à toi
he tous les jours continue alors on va
se retrouver dans un instant